[Music]
this morning our special series of work
shift looks at how working remotely
during this pandemic has helped fuel the
movement of city dwellers to more rural
areas i like how that graphic changes
according to the us postal service
nearly 16 million people moved during
the pandemic some for families some for
financial reasons while others just
wanted more space and they wanted to be
closer to nature mola lange takes us on
a journey into new york's hudson valley
to see what's drawing people from the
big city and how the new arrivals are
transforming the region
the pandemic permanently shifted not
only the way some people think but the
way we work more than two hundred
thousand new yorkers moved out of the
city just last year many of them
planting new routes in upstate new york
that's where we're headed to check out
the new work normal
our first stop is barn fox it's a
co-working space that's seen its
membership jump since the pandemic began
it's like a little getaway outside the
big city
it's a space to work it's also a space
for people to connect so we envision
this future of movement away from the
urban
landscape to a more rural landscape
so pandemic hits how does that impact
how does that accelerate
what you guys are doing at first it
slowed down because nobody knew what was
going on uncertainty yeah but after a
few months more people were moving to
the area needed a place to work so
definitely sped up the process we were
just getting an influx of memberships
coming in
so we knew that it was we were sort of
in the right place at the right time
yeah timing seemed to be kind of perfect
right yeah
[Music]
the pandemic and time away from the city
had in fact changed me and i think i was
i just got clear that i was looking for
a different balance i left the city i
had always thought about being somewhere
with more green space and closer to
nature was the pandemic kind available
kingston new york is about a hundred
miles north of new york city home prices
here jumped 18
just in the last two years compare that
to the national average of four percent
it's the largest home price jump in the
country
[Music]
i'm the head of the upstate real estate
team nine percent of the clients that we
work with
are either coming from the city moving
up here or they're second homeowners who
primarily live in the city and then
we're selling their homes with the
increased demand
uh means that
home prices property prices have
increased as well
yep
yeah they have from july of 2020 to july
of 2021 ulster county where we're
driving through right now the increase
was a little over 20 percent 20 in
prices media yep
well i mean that's significant it's yeah
it's huge
i mean that is a delicate balance of
trying to maintain the characteristic
and the personality of this place
because it's such a unique personality
well 100 and the people who are most
interested in preserving the open space
and the like and the environment and all
these things are the least likely to
want there to be additional housing
build and that's what exacerbates the
affordable housing issue oh my god
you're so good at this thank you no
thank you
i appreciate it no thank you and thanks
for putting up with my driving i don't
have a driver's license i just made all
that up so
for nearly a hundred years this was the
general store here in woodstock now it's
toronto market which is helping to
diversify the culinary and grocery
options here in the catskills but for
some it's much more than just a store
when we come here we belong here we feel
like it's like home second home we have
asian groceries in the front of the
market and then in the back
i'm essentially putting out filipino
food inspired by my grandmother there
was a void in this community that you're
feeling absolutely but also showing up
to a store where you like see yourself
reflected more than the physical grocery
items i think that's a void that people
are responding to over here also
bringing to light the people who have
been here you know the the queer folks
the asians that have been living just
down the road no one really knew about
it yeah and like it's like people have
cried in our store it just started like
actually multiple it happens all the
time have just started like literally
crying and that's not about the food
that they're eating or the groceries
that's good yeah
this is so good but it's it's all of it
it's the smell it's the experience
during the pandemic there are very few
things that are unilaterally good and
hirano market opening is one of them
during the rise of anti-asian hate you
know became a really vulnerable moment
where you needed that sense of community
the space has really become like a
meeting point of sorts as much as you
can during covid safely meet so part of
us is like creating an inclusive space
for
all of our neighbors those who have been
here for a long time those who are new
and maybe they can spark conversations
as well amongst themselves
new neighbors finding their way to give
back one thing we learned on this trip
the pandemic has shifted some people's
mindsets pushing folks outside closer to
nature to find more balance that's one
word we keep hearing balance perhaps
that's easy to find in a place like this
for cbs this morning mola leggy
catskills new york
molly you can't take your eyes off the
road
look at the camera
i'm
but i did like the way that he did the
interview talking to the lady when they
were driving of course he does have a
heaven he does a license what are you
saying i was saying
and you guys we all live in the city i i
was born in new york city but i whenever
i see pieces like that and i visit
friends like my sister lives in
rochester i'm like could i nice do you
do you guys ever feel that way
i've always i've always lived in the
suburbs suburbs until i moved to the
city i love the suburbs i love having
grass i love having a yard it's more
than the suburbs that's rural what's
that term they had barn fox
i like that barn whatever you like fake
grass in your backyard
i like the kindness of the people there
that's what i like about anything else
but it's just so nice